super zoo the most attended pet industry
trade show in north america is taking
place right now over at mandalay bay
convention center this week over a
thousand brands are putting their best
paw forward as they unveil new product
launches that are going to leave pets
just drooling for more and we have pet
lifestyle expert stephanie krull in
studio to discuss this year's standout
attendees and we have a special friend
with us too who is this yeah this is
frolick and frolic is actually one of
the lisa vanderpump dogs he was she was
rescued from the beijing meat market so
a rescue pup and just like your segment
before rescue is not a trend we'll
always be in style that is the way to go
and we're so happy to have frolic here
with us let's talk about some of these
amazing products that you can find at
super zoo and you can get what's this
first one i we know our dogs love treats
right definitely so this is a a newer
company been in the industry for a few
years but this is because animals and
fill this packaging this is made of
recycled water bottles oh my gosh so
another big trend is the pet industry
really cares about our environment yes
not only are pets but mother earth so um
and because animals they have the bmu
nutritional yeast so nutritional yeast
is not only good for us but our pets too
yeah i bet and i love i love that
they're finding ways to help the
environment too absolutely
okay we got to talk about this because i
think this is one of the most brilliant
ideas look at this i'm not going to tell
you what it is yet just look at it those
look like rice cornmeal something what
is it you got the corn so this is from
this is natural cat litter from
sustainably yours so this is actually
made of corn and cassava root wow so
like a potato and you know this is
really popular because look it's it's a
light color so if your cat and you felt
how soft it was yes but if your cat's
also having urinary issues you would see
it right in the if there's blood in the
urine you would see it like normal kitty
litter you couldn't see those issues
that is absolutely brilliant why did
they think of that i don't know and
speaking of smart i love this next
product line this is from rover wellness
okay and this is just delicious this is
their canine wellness free dry bites so
this is not only
with the broad spectrum hemp oil
no thc but also so smart they put fish
oil in it so it not only calms your pet
but also helps with mobility
heart health too i would assume all of
that
so check out their website
roverwellness.com a lot of information
there i feel like these these animals
are eating better than most humans now
they have such a pain absolutely and
speaking of which you know you're always
going to want to look for made in the
usa for pet food and treats so this is a
company that's celebrating 30 years this
is charlie bear so they have some
delicious
flavors that they're launching
egg and bacon
pb j it's so delicious okay and like
does it is it weird that i kind of want
to try this yeah
delicious that one's really good and
they're so smart because you know when
treats kind of crumble in your pocket
yes these won't so this is so ask for
charlie bear do you want to charlie bear
look it yeah she's our little frolic's
our charlie bear spokes model so perfect
thank you for all of these amazing
products and if people want more
information just ask for these products
that you're getting they'll be coming to
your store soon just ready in time for
the holidays
thank you so much